[Musica]
i ragazzi benvenuti a questo nuovo video
io sono fatti j questo è un intro che è
la prima volta che faccio infatti sono
un pò emozionato oggi ragazzi un ospite
speciale che ci introduce google e
google
chi è noemi secondo wikipedia noemi seno
tonico di veronica scopelliti è una
cantautrice e personaggio televisivo
italiana veronica scopelliti
ciao ciao carissima belli questi
ragazzini magari che ti sei natalizia
ragazzi abbiamo qua veronica che però
non è veronica questa la domanda di
spiegare spiega perché non sia lì
veronica 1 milione
in realtà mi chiamo giovanni perché
grazie perché noi anni la canonica
scopelliti è un nome un po lungo invece
volevo una cosa piccola brave mia mamma
mi vorrà chiamare noemi e quindi non mi
basta facciamo che compare il parco tra
3 2 1 ok hai visto come comparsa la
magia dell'editing iscrivetevi al canale
grazie mille non so cosa c'è all'interno
del pacco ogni volta loro meno fermo
appositamente
incredibile andiamo con veronica noemi
veronica de scatolare appunto il bacoli
oggi ma solo dio sa niente
rovinato la metà delle cose c'erano
dentro no aspetteranno prima cosa
attenzione che stamani suo mani per
detto vi prendete prima che ci uccidiamo
ama bellissimi qualsiasi cosa c'è qua
dentro non tavole porta a casa perché le
pago io
vai dai propri concetto che sceglie il
primogenito bari tiro fuori
allora abbiamo una che fa i concerti
spesso immagino che chiude battuti di
dare molti mesi che tra di strumenti
musicali
c'è qui una rapina ma è credibile non
questo fosse vero wow gli potrei
iniziare mito è stato mai mai n'è
un'altra che non sono serviti io di
fletcher che anche allora sì mi la tua
canzone qualsiasi migliore mi minore per
avere la minima maggio revocate lo
stesso guardando la passano male così
ben minore vana by 3 2 1
stato cinese come accordato una bella mi
piace sonorità piccola e inciso da una
chitarra così minacciati anche adesso
della regalo non è che mi appassiona
va bene mai adesso scelgo io e quello
che penso le pensioni non ti dirò come
la prima volta che lo vedo ranieri
allora chi serve il marimba benissimo
moscheta 774 allo stand ora il mio tre
poi mi arrabbio di nuovo a disneyland e
fischi estensi c'è freddie mercury e
della gamba sta facendo la casa allora
io dovrei su questo che è molto piccolo
questa è la batteria finissima tu non ha
mai suonato
io non ho mai soprattutto partita ma
miss panissa che questo non e google
metti una canzone dei queen per favore
bravo carino sempre dei contratti tipo
al momento non riesco a far partire
adesso del testa batteria bella ha
ammesso della batteria pezzo della
batteria ragazzi quindi li facciamo i
queen che ne so bene e questo è stato il
nostro a nostra ora il montaggio per
andare quando avevi di giocattoli tipo
musicale la piccola allora è quando ero
piccola ed orologi giocattoli musicale
avevo mia zia che aveva una chitarra
fighissima allora potrà mai toccare
nessuno era tipo chiusa del popolo
iniziato la tua che volevo che la
chitarra
è bello chiara invece mio padre insomma
è stato mio padre suona davvero li
mettiamo insieme che fanno notare
sezionate quando ho iniziato ad
approccio la mia musica mio padre
suonava la chitarra pianoforte e mio
padre voleva che io accetto giustissimo
roseo avvicinarsi così andiamo avanti a
scusa papa allora il prossimo lo prendo
sempre io perché non c'è attività ma
questo è saxobeat e sembra una cosa
brutta a dirlo ok allora questa qua lo
usiamo a san siro 6 voglia volta che vai
a san siro usa questo ai prego che
carino sembra chi è signore di cui c'era
la richiesta maestro pajo vejo molta
meno barbari vessicchio suona e canta di
schio stai fissi ma quelle cose da
mangiare ti guarda e mangio no che
diceva fatto e cosa mangiare poi
riguarda medici e mangia qualsiasi cosa
io sono scorso mese poi mia razza avremo
nei campi letti di bohemian se lo vuoi
con lauto regalo è perché mi sai
indicare grande però è intelligente con
colla per ridotto a fare
non funziona sanità p prova bene provato
sino io direi di the scatolare l'ultimo
giallo così che va il mio più allora
ferito questo è difficile perché lo sai
suonare questo confronto
allora non era affatto un software
veronica scusa va fatto un sacco di
tanning per suonare il pianoforte oggi
questo lo sognano
non so quanto ci mettiamo a metterlo su
tirare tiferà io resto definisci mi
questo pezzo del pianoforte
si chiama così se hai voglia se vuoi
tipo a costruire un altro sgambetto non
so se come sei messo un mese quindi non
ammettere che sì potrei parlare per la
nostra via è mai costruito un arca cagno
fan club e il suo fan club e mi ero mai
cosa a me sono tutto ti ricordi ragazzi
hanno mai ho allora 2003 dai presidi
2013 questa è la nostra prima foto
guarda che bella faccia che ciò venisse
non buttiamo carico si giocano così
giovani anche io perché detto il prof la
stiamo morendo ragazzi ricordateci così
sei pronta ma da marino
[Musica]
[Applauso]
i tuoi biglietti ritorno su ticketone sì
c'era anche il microfono dalla cassa 4
alla cassina remi la cassa 4 io non so
cosa dire però se vogliamo persone ma se
molto dai cosa il nostro primo con il
nostro primo concerto non posso più
tornare a stare insieme in che senso
vieni con me ma guardate che magia in
piedi ma dalla famiglia capire chi siamo
esattamente alle rende poi ci chiamiamo
di tokyo
i tocchi ostello che possiamo dire a
casa ma guarda dove ti ha portato
[Applauso]
cominciamo bene prima cosa suoniamo
guarda io farei un omaggio
mamma mia non mi dispiace fresco
mangiamo freddo e chieti lo fi 3g fallo
ti faccio io mai e pronti e carichi
questo progetto pagato il biglietto
tanti vip ma va
a schiera
[Musica]
[Applauso]
solo questo ma vero
perché non farne funzione questa tv di
stato sbagliato ragazzi facciamo che
facciamo a cantare una persona seria che
io non è che sto proprio al massimo 70 c
qualcosa di così tre comunque starei
bellissimo
grazie a questo reggiseno tutti su cole
accendini sono un peso per me stesso
sono un vuoto a perdere
ecco tesi ma senza le 90 e le ed ora
sono qui che guardo e riguardo crescere
la mia celli delle mie nuove e papà ti
dirò come mai
[Musica]
gira strada vado ancora amministrate
affari con gesti va bene troviamo nemi a
fare i concetti per strada sentimenti
adeguati io veramente vi ringrazio per
questo video che è stato veramente
splendido a tutti voi e soprattutto
ringrazio però non è vero vi ringrazio
che ci arrivo per questo splendido video
è stato molto divertente ragazzi quindi
vi lascio vi lascio suonare a voi gli
strumenti perché io non penso di essere
in grado ringrazio navy per aver
partecipato a questo video vi lascio
mista grandi temi in discussione chi non
la segue non gli viene il cag 8 ma il
senso è quello
[Risate]
spero che vi sia piaciuto e noi ci
vediamo come sempre
[Applauso]
[Musica]